so i i want to i want to show this here
uh anatomy of the state so uh most of
you uh maybe if you missed it we we're
just mentioning how jack dorsey the ceo
of twitter ever woke
tweeted out
murray rothbard
anatomy of the state libertarians and
anarcho-capitalists were all hooting and
hollering and freaking out and on page
six which is you know the opening of
anatomy of the state which jack dorsey
himself posted
the greatest danger to the state is
independent intellectual criticism
my own mind
it's very interesting that uh jack
dorsey would tweet something like that
out considering twitter actively tries
to suppress intellectual criticism of
the state
maybe maybe jack he's like he's actually
locked in a basement
and he's like you know and and they run
everything and he he broke out and he's
all gaunt and frail and like they're
coming to bring his food and the door
opens and like here's your food dorsey
and then he shoves the guy out of the
way and he runs the computer and he hits
control c control v an enemy say enter
and they're like no and they grab him
they're dragging him back and he's like
no freedom
and he can like see the matrix as he's
being pulled back and they throw him
back in the room don't you ever pulse
them like that again and then you know
uh the other twitter exacts running like
what did dorsey do he escaped from his
cell and he tweeted out
rothbard and then they were like oh can
we delete it no the next time he
testifies in front of congress we'll
have to watch as he blinks to see if he
blinks sos
he's got like uh he's got like a brain
chip he's like a thing on his temple and
it like shorts out for a second and he's
like i can i can think again and he goes
to the computer and he sends it and then
they're like oh guys you got to reboot
dorsey's mind control chip
and he goes
like the v chip from south park
yeah
yeah so uh of all the people
you know but but i'll i'll say this when
it comes to jack dorsey
i talked to him um you know before the
rogan podcast and he was talking about
blockchain and i think he's really naive
i think he doesn't know he doesn't know
what he's talking about i think he's uh
to be completely honest nice guy
a bit duplicitous uh right place and
right time twitter is not particularly
complicated he's he said we discovered
twitter we didn't invent twitter things
like that and when i was talking to him
um before we did the rogan podcast like
literally like minutes before he was
saying how he really wanted blockchain
based social media
and he was like that way once it's there
it's like there forever and i'm like
that sounds horrible that sounds like
the worst idea ever like imagine you're
15 you know when you're like i'm gonna
post a picture of my ass
cause i'm edgy and i got 10 followers
and i don't care and then you're 30 and
you're like you know you've got 50 000
followers now and you're a sports
commentator and then they're like good
now but noticed in your immutable ledger
use a picture of your ass it's like
i know i can't get i can it's in the
blockchain what am i supposed to do
about it it's there forever in theory
what that should mean is that we all
kind of get that to get out of jail free
for doing dumb stuff but what it what in
practice it means is if you did dumb
stuff that the elite don't approve of
you know you can get canceled at
absolutely any point in time in your
life but if they're okay with the dumb
stuff you know you you know you are a
part of you know an anti-far you know
attack or something oh yeah that's fine
we don't care that's fine you get a nice
reuters article
you were once a noble activist fighting
for justice tell me how that went well i
threw a bunch of bottles at people and
then we went around smashing things oh
wow sounds like fun sounds like you've
accomplished a lot in your life yes it
was hard but we burned down some bars
that's basically the the history of
these people when they're older there's
a video uh that went viral of um a
journalist
who is trying to cover what's going on
in portland and this antifa gets in her
face
and says that like you are endangering
people by spreading kovid which is like
the craziest thing for antifa i guess to
say they're pro state whatever and then
they they physically attack her throw to
the ground spray with paint and mace or
whatever
these people
they
they're they're effectively
around what the brown shirts you know
they're they're enforcing state edict or
whatever they march around these cities
doing literally nothing
believing cnn and thinking they oppose
the state when they're doing everything
the state would want them to do
yeah i mean the brown shirts entirely
they say oh we're we're the original
anti-fascists and they you know post
images you'll see idiots like people at
cnn posting images of you know d-day
landing and like oh you know
anti-fascists and then comparing them
chris cuomo uh you know to antiphon and
i'm like no these are the worst of the
gutter trash who go attack ordinary
people on the street
and try to bully people just because
they think or say different things i
don't support anybody doing that i don't
care what ideology you've got if you're
going and just walking up to people and
attacking them on the street you're in
the wrong i think that's a historically
speaking we've proven that do you see
when they were attacking people who are
protesting covert restrictions
i'm like isn't that weird the state
comes out and makes like like bill de
blasio decrees something that's like not
even a law it's a decree from executor
and they're like we're gonna defend that
and so you come out and be like the
there was actually an event happened in
dc where a bunch of conservatives came
down to protest corporate censorship
and antifa showed up calling them
fascists and started attacking people
and i'm like yo are they
are they pro corporation
is like antifa
pro
oh dude they're fascists yeah they're
pro-censorship and the whole left is
including the major media check this out
antifa i used to say this wasn't the
case i would say antifa is not fascist
because they do not agree with like
traditional values or nationalism
but based on mussolini's definition of
the corporation in the state the merger
antifa are legitimately fascists
they support corporate censorship they
have beaten people in defense of
corporations and they've beaten people
in defense of the state it is absolutely
insane to see that and this is the game
they play it's like with ibrahim kennedy
and critical race applied principles he
calls himself anti-racist and then when
we had papa john on the show he kept
calling himself anti-racist and i told
him like anti-racist means you support
discrimination based on race and he
didn't get it he kept saying anti-racist
and i'm like
when people want to use it against you
they will ibram candy supports
discrimination based on race critical
race theory supports discrimination
based on race and they call that
anti-racism because it's a word game to
manipulate people who don't pay
attention right it's about the same
thing yeah you know we've replaced we've
we've gone full circle where now the
very people who go around saying oh you
can't be racist are then going around
saying racist stuff you can get shut
down on twitter or social media for
saying anything racist in some groups
but not against others and it's the game
look at the the anti-semitism you see on
these sites is just off the charts and
you see it not just on social media but
on
you know in schools and colleges
universities
the jewish you know the these jewish
students everywhere are now
a target when they go to college i you
know that's the exact kind of thing
that we look back at history books and
say gee that was awful when it happened
in the 1930s why are we allowing it to
happen here
in
this era
yeah
i i love uh i'm just reading you know i
have the anatomy of the state pulled up
and just for jack dorsey to tweet
something referring to the state is
parasitic and sapping production and
stuff like that i'm like wow
maybe he should apply those principles
to the companies that he runs you know
maybe things would get a little bit
better
but uh i hate to say it themes it just
seems like things are getting worse and
worse and even even with what's going on
in afghanistan and everyone kind of
turning their back on biden it's not
it's not in any way to imply that things
will improve no i mean i think
unfortunately
look i i thought we shouldn't be in
afghanistan anywhere near the length of
time we were i mean it
if you follow anything about history we
changed the mission
our military is really good at going
kicking somebody's ass just is now
but they're not good at forcing you to
come into the 21st century and embrace
western values it's just
it's unfair ask of anybody and so they
went from being
war fighters to
prison guards and social workers and
that's just you know i don't care
whether you're carrying the ak-47 or m16
or whatever you're carrying
if you're trying to convince somebody
to join the 21st century when he you
know he can't even read
that's just the wrong mission that's why
it's 100 it's a 100 year mission you
have to raise several generations and
instill in them like a norm but to go
into a country where there's al like you
know we're there we're there for 20
years
if you went to the american people and
said we want to be here for a hundred
years to colonize and reclaim people
would be like get out of here they would
not support that well it's also it's
also geographically really difficult
afghanistan is a landlocked nation we're
we're the world's greatest navy okay
that's just
bad dynamics so if you're gonna do it
and it didn't work well when we did it
in vietnam i mean so because
you have to look it's just like when you
go buy a house i'm i drive out here get
the wonderful compound see see the nice
area
when you buy a house you buy a
neighborhood well afghanistan's in a
really bad neighborhood it's got
pakistan next door and they're run by
looney tunes people it's got china next
door they're even worse russia's nearby
i mean it is iran is next
and it's exactly the same problem i mean
vietnam had when you've got china a
nation now of 1.3 billion people nearby
and you're another nation trying to end
up with a sane destiny it doesn't matter
whether you're taiwan or afghanistan
you're going to have trouble
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you